but you know the whole starchitect
phenomenon I think is sort of three
parts good one part bad maybe I mean the
bad part is simply that the American
culture of celebrity was inevitably
gonna hit architecture and and have its
way with it and so we're I think have
taken at least some architects and made
them into celebrities about whom we owe
and are rather than really analyze their
work and think about it thoughtfully but
that's a risk in art in music and
literature it happens everywhere to some
extent the good side of this all is that
it there is a far greater interest in
architecture today than there has been
at any time I think in our lifetimes
really you know architecture is now part
of a general cultural dialogue what I
was starting my career it wasn't you
know it was kind of this little thing
off to the side even though it
influenced everybody everybody dealt
with architecture every day of their
lives people didn't pay that much
attention to it generally and didn't
think of it as something that influenced
their daily lives and so they would
maybe talk about music they would talk
about art they talk about books but
architecture wasn't on that radar screen
with the others now it is in a very
different way and so inevitably that's
going to create more interest in more
buildings that will get people engaged
and excited and so the more people see
of buildings that arouse their passions
whether positively or negatively the
more they kind of want more and because
we are a more visual culture than we
used to be which i think is also
basically good or more good than not
good we're doing more to accentuate that
so of course you know the art museum
it's not an original observation to say
that the art museum is kind of the
secular cathedral of our time and in in
so many cities now the art museum is the
physical symbol of the
the statement this community is making
to the world that it has a certain kind
of stature in the very same way that
once building a cathedral was that
statement to the world and even if the
art museum isn't the tallest thing in
town it's often now the most important
the building over which the most care
has been lavished the most attention the
most time the most money and so you know
all that is is mostly to the good but in
life you know an architecture as in life
very few things are 100% good removers
that bad and you know there's no free
lunch we pay a price for that but it's
still mostly a positive thing
I think inevitably you would have to say
Frank Gehry has had the most profound
effect because he's the architect who
bridges the sort of serious world of
architecture those who study
architecture academically or practice it
or think of it you know in a critical
way within that world and popular
culture and there are very few examples
in history of an architect being that
bridge and creating buildings that
excited and engaged a very broad segment
of the population at the same time that
the most serious critics were treating
them with respect to something and
viewing them as something important and
so Gary undoubtedly has had the greatest
effect greatest impact of any architect
certainly over the last 20 25 years and
is probably the heir in the United
States at least to the sort of legacy of
Louie Kahn as a kind of you know
philosopher king of architects somebody
who's both very thoughtful and did great
buildings that had a profound impact
although right now you know there's a
whole generation of other significant
architects who have made a big mark on
the landscape and will continue to so
while I agree that Gary's the most
important right now he's far from the
freshest face him and it's in no way to
say that the story of architecture in
the last 20 years begins and ends with
him it neither begins with him nor ends
with him actually he's just the figure
around whom a lot of the phenomenon of
our time have kind of coalesced the most
clearly